facile à la limite à voir quel candidat
peut réclamer les mêmes voies que vous
oui d'accord mais personne ne le fait
c'est ça le problème c'est que
généralement les petits fours qui je me
présente il n'existe pas en politique
c'est à dire tout le monde les prendre
pour rien quoi et simplement ce que je
leur propose c'est de renvoyer le
complément homme politique je crois pas
que quelqu'un qui soit ennuyer s'agit
brice lalonde doit pas être très content
pourquoi je sens de lui par année dans l
excellent écologistes je prends les voix
des abstentionnistes personne ne les a
jamais eu la gauche avait une chance de
gagner quand elle était unie mais elle
l'est plus donc elle n'a aucune chance
de gagner donc on est on est devant une
mascarade politique n'est pas répandue
si effectivement je fais que résonnent
candidature si votre candidature a pour
principal résultat d'augmenter encore la
barre pour pour que les gens puissent se
présenter est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est un c'est un risque et soudan et
gagne ou perde pas ce que vous croyez
que les gens qui gouvernent donc la
répression comme moyen d'expression eh
bien vous avez raison c'est bien sûr
contre soi je lutte justement je suis
pas d'accord qu'ils emmerdent avec des
lois antidémocratiques alors que il
clame partout on est dans une démocratie